hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es
allererste rezept was für die wm gedacht
ist übermorgen spielt deutschland gegen
mexiko und da habe ich gedacht so party
salate kommen immer gut an falls die
gäste bekommt und den kann man auch sehr
gut vorbereiten wir machen einen
mexikanischen takko salat normalerweise
kommt der chili con carne rein aber mir
gefällt die vorstellung nicht dass da
kaltes hat vielleicht drin ist das ding
machen wir jetzt zuallererst chilis sin
carne und dann zeige ich euch die
weitere zubereitung wir benötigen
gestückelte tomaten aus der dose
zwiebeln knoblauch und öl
außerdem mais und kidney bohnen und hier
an gewürzen salz pfeffer paprika flocken
oder chili kreuzkümmel und paprikapulver
außerdem noch zum abrunden etwas zarter
schokolade
der erste schritt ist jetzt in einer
beschichteten pfanne etwas öl zu
erhitzen und anschließend zwiebeln und
knoblauch darin zu dünsten
[Musik]
nachdem wir das auf mittlerer stufe
glasig gedünstet habt gebt ihr den rest
dazu das heißt tomaten bohnen mais und
die gewürze
[Musik]
jetzt sind die gewürze auch alle drin
und ich gebe hier jetzt noch ein
bisschen wasser mit rein ich das jetzt
einfach mal diese schüssel auf damit ich
noch den rest der tomatensauce raushole
aber nur ein bisschen
das war der verrückteste zwar sprecher
aber wir brauchen wir wollen es auch
keine richtig flüssiger schädigung oder
chinesin kang ist er ohne fleisch
sondern das kommt ja auf dem salat
deswegen dachte nicht so flüssig sein
also gibt erstmal ein bisschen was drauf
und anschließend auf kochen decke drüber
und dann köcheln lassen am besten nach
halbe stunde
wer ist eigentlich hat kann auch 15
minuten lang köcheln lassen aber halbe
stunde ist auf jeden fall besser
mindestens
[Musik]
jetzt sucht er das ganze eine halbe
stunde auf mittlerer stufe köcheln gerne
auch länger falls ihr zeit ab lässt es
gerne stunde drauf aber eine halbe
stunde reicht mir ist vollkommen ihr
dürft auch zwischendurch mal umrühren
noch am topfboden nichts an klebt und
jetzt gehen wir noch die butter
schokolade rein und falls ihr euch fragt
was hat die darin zu suchen die rundet
den geschmack noch mal ab und gibt auch
noch mal ein bisschen farbe ab sobald
die schokolade dann in diesem chili con
carne ein gerät und geschmolzen ist muss
das ganze erstmal abkühlen und dann geht
es weiter dann zeige ich euch auch
gleich die nächsten zutaten und falls
ihr euch jetzt fragte wo ist die
chilischote ich bin ganz ehrlich zu euch
ich kann schaaf ist überhaupt nicht
vertragen ich bin da so ein richtiges
weichei genauso wie haben sie deswegen
haben wir gesagt okay wir tun es keine
chili reihen dieses paprikapulver dass
das schaf ist reiten schon aber ihr
könnt natürlich dann auch gerne mit rein
geben sobald die schokolade dann
eingerührt und geschmolzen ist lassen
wir das vollständig ab gründerfonds
weitergeht ich werde sie aber jetzt
schon mal meine form einmal umfüllen und
zwar habe ich mir überlegt ich damit
eine breite auflaufform und keine hohe
glasform sorge sie mich ganz auf dem
internet gesehen und ich finde das
ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen unpraktisch
wenn man dann so reingeht und alles
kaputt geht deshalb schicht ich das
lieber in einer breiten auflaufform
[Musik]
wir benötigen tortilla chips die habe
ich jetzt hier mit käse geschmack
außerdem eisbergsalat in mundgerechte
stücke geschnitten etwas cheddar käse
kleine tomaten die habe ich geviertelt
und creme fraiche und das verzeihe ich
jetzt noch mit salz und pfeffer
[Musik]
jetzt ist unser chili endlich
ausgekühlten es geht weiter denn letzte
schritt dann geht total schnell und
einfach nur alle schichten
ich war das am nächsten so dass ich
jetzt eisbergsalat und tomaten hat er
auf tour und dann geht's weiter
[Musik]
als nächstes kommt jetzt creme fraiche
jahre war ihr könnt auch schon dessen
schmandt nehmen quark oder joghurt würde
ich euch aber an der stelle nicht
empfehlen das schmeckt dann nicht so gut
[Musik]
ich persönlich finde das total schön
wenn man hier noch so ein bisschen den
salat und die tomaten sieht und eben
dann kein flash nicht ganz bis zum rand
verteilt und jetzt geben wir unseren
chat käse darüber
[Musik]
der salat so schon richtig lecker
aussieht am liebsten schon sofort zum
den keller nehmen auf einen teller aber
es wird noch ein entscheidende zutat und
zwar unsere nachos die gebe ich jetzt
noch drüber beachtet bitte dass ihr die
erst kurz vor dem verzehr aufgibt und
werden so richtig weich und dann
schmeckt einfach nicht mehr
[Musik]
und somit ist der natur bzw takko salat
endlich fertig und kann sofort serviert
werden ich habe noch meine frage an euch
was tippt ihr wäre jetzt am sonntag
gewinnt mein persönliches gefühl sagt
jetzt 2 2 1 für deutschland was sagst du
hansa 30 deutschland glaubst du die
mexikaner machen nicht nur ein tor
die waren gut so aber können also wenn
das so wenn das ist unsere mexikanischen
zuschauer hören
also ich bin raus ich habe gesagt ich
schieße ein tor so jetzt freue ich mich
natürlich wenn ihr diesen salat nach
macht denn den sieht auf dem tisch
einfach mega gut aus nicht wie die
anderen langweiligen salat wenn ich so
sagen darf weil der mache ich etwas her
und könnte so die hauptrolle auf eurem
fußball tischspielen die genauen
mengenangaben stehen wie immer unten in
der infobox paket nicht gerne mit dem
hashtag description auf instagram und
dann sei es bis zum nächsten mal tschüss
[Musik]